have you ever wondered how talking
therapy works maybe you suffered a
bereavement been feeling down or anxious
or just overwhelmed and you're starting
to think you should talk to someone
perhaps you've tried talking to friends
or family but they don't seem to quite
understand or they have too much on
their plates so you consider therapy but
you have doubts what if you're not ill
enough to see a professional will it
feel awkward talking to a stranger will
they make you lie down on a couch and
Reveal Your innermost secrets
in the UK you can get talking therapy
free on the NHS but waiting times can
vary significantly private therapists
can be expensive although some do offer
lower fees for those who can't afford to
pay more but let's say you've arranged
your first session and you're wondering
how exactly it might help
the good news is that therapy can
actually change the way your brain
functions in a positive way our brains
are a little bit like Play-Doh capable
of adapting reshaping and rebuilding
this is known as neural plasticity
whilst in therapy your brain circuits
are able to remold and reconnect in
different ways meaning we're able to
reframe negative or obsessive Thinking
by shifting our thinking we start to
strengthen different pathways so when
you talk through stressful feelings and
strong emotions in therapy you're
rewiring your brain a bit like rewiring
an electrical circuit therapy also
activates the hormone serotonin and can
help improve our ability to cope with
stress
studies found that the brains and people
who've had therapy for depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder showed
improvements that were as good as SSRI
antidepressant treatments even short
courses of therapy can be beneficial
they often use techniques known as CBT
or cognitive behavioral therapy this can
be particularly useful in helping you
change specific behaviors or negative
thinking patterns because it focuses
attention on your problems and helps you
develop coping strategies
in 2020 to 21 over 630
000 people completed the NHS talking
Therapy Program in England averaging
seven and a half sessions with a
therapist
51.4 percent of those who completed the
program for anxiety or depression
recovered the most important factor
determining whether therapy works for
you is the quality of the relationship
you have with your therapist this is
actually more important than the type of
therapy you choose or the therapist's
experience
so if you don't get on with the first
therapist you meet it's worth
persevering and looking for a new one
your level of motivation is also
important as is the therapist's ability
to recognize which type of support is
best
suggesting weekly homework might do
wonders for some but be completely
off-pussing for others so why can
therapy be better than talking to a
friend for starters you get your
therapist undivised attention and you
don't have to worry about what they
think of you you can cry your eyes out
they won't judge you unlike with a
friend you don't have to worry about
hurting your therapist's feelings then
there's confidentiality unless a
therapist thinks you're at risk of
harming yourself or others whatever you
say in the therapist's office stays in a
therapist's office a friend might offer
advice which even if well intended might
not be right for you a good therapist
usually won't offer advice but instead
listen summarize what you said and
reflects it back to you this simple
technique can help you see things from a
different perspective
unlike a friend who may be quick to
agree with you a therapist can challenge
you in a supportive way and without
being challenged you may not find new
ways of thinking or behaving of course
therapy doesn't work for everyone in
every situation serious mental health
conditions can require drug treatment or
even an inpatient stay
other people find self-help techniques
such as meditation are enough for them
but overall studies show that a typical
client is better off for having gone
through the process in fact according to
the NHS in 2022 over 66 percent of
people who entered therapy found it
beneficial
in the words of American writer Carly J
Hansen therapy didn't fix me therapy
gave me the tools to help me fix myself
over and over again for the rest of my
life
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video